what if I told you you don't need to
carry on home schooling your children
well not for English in any case we know
that being at home has suddenly meant
that you've become professional cooks
cleaners teachers as well as continuing
with your day job we're taking your
child's English lessons online virtual
lessons are designed to provide the same
progress as regular lessons in a fun and
productive manner I must say a talented
student that's great English there will
be an element of interactive guided
learning before and after the class I
really like exercise sleep this is to
make sure your child gets the most out
of their online English learning
experience the virtual lessons platform
is easy to use and say so what will your
child need they'll need a laptop with
audio and video features they'll need to
be in a suitably quiet place with
minimal distraction there's no way she's
gonna be learning English they'll also
need to have a good Wi-Fi connection you
really do not want to find yourself in
that situation the platform we use will
allow your child to participate in power
well now it's raining child protection
of that but most important to us we have
very strict anti-bullying policies along
with other housekeeping rules then you
can read about on our website learning
online will build your house confidence
their resilience their digital skills
and their communication skills if you
have any questions please do not
hesitate to contact your local british
council centre can you help with biology
we're sticking to english we look
forward to seeing your child in an
online lesson really see
[Music]